hi isla Mikey shot you were amazing
so do you mean Allah but tan everything
you're just refreshing yeah I've just
come off an imaginary holiday in my five
on the beach of the Bahamas yes oh are
you gonna get to do that at some point
no I am actually going away for spring
break though which I'm excited about
good good so let's talk about margin
charge
you've got your third one and the final
one of the series what a fun book what
inspired it I think I was uh well I
wrote a couple of teen romance fiction
books when I was a teenager and I really
enjoyed that process and so and I've
always loved telling stories I grew up
loving books my grandmother actually was
a quadriplegic for most of my life and
she would read and reread all the books
she loved in her youth so I was a
bookworm and so telling stories in in
particularly for kids now that I have my
own was just was just a natural
transition yeah would you say writing is
your first love I definitely think it's
been more of my sort of Savior my dad I
went to a different school every year of
my life until high school actually
because we traveled a lot and I was born
in the Middle East and then we moved to
England and then we moved to Australia
and so yeah I've always loved writing
and reading and telling stories and but
I'll always love acting of course and
the fun thing about acting is the travel
and that you get to kind of inhabit the
emotional landscape of a character
whereas when you write you get to
inhabit the landscape of all your
characters so it's sort of more of a
it's just it's it's more absorbing in a
way and you get more control which is
fun yeah I know you've said in the past
that you would adapt the book into a TV
series do you have anybody in mind to
play Marsh you know I sort of think
about Betty White yeah just because
she's obviously what I love about the
book says it's a celebration of you know
a relationship with an older person
who's not necessarily a grandparent and
I feel like you know nowadays old people
kind of get faster
you know cast aside so I'd love someone
like Betty who's you know wise and and
hilarious and she has sort of pathos in
drama but equally she brings so many
jokes to comedy movies she'd be my dream
dream actor
yeah this is the moment this is the
moment yeah I was like wait a minute I
feel ok um who does Marg sound like to
you or like how does she sound um well
she's from she's a duchess yeah which we
don't know whether she really is and so
you know she would have a posh accent
and I when I do the voices for the
audiobooks and for my kids in the
evening which is how that she kind of
came I want to hear the voice and I'd be
the child for a minute my name is
Victoria loves puns of foix and I am a
Duchess is that silly you know it's
whatever makes kids laugh you want to
you know you want to push it a little
bit more and yeah I love that
ah it's so fun and you know what's great
about being a ride and when you're not a
real writer you know I don't do it as
real right now I'm an actor who gets
lucky enough to get books published but
it's just that you know you get the
connection to tiny readers which is so
fun you know when grown-ups come up and
say I like the movie that you did it's
obviously very flattering and I'm always
you know very friendly but when it's a
kid that does one of the characters
catchphrases from the book or asks me a
story you know a question about one of
the stories I did think it's so sweet
this is so cute and they dress up as
much of a book week you particularly in
England and Australia so that's very
cute yeah your children when you're
reading the book do they give you advice
ever on where they want the story to go
absolutely and I have an editor who's
around my age and she sort of tells me
to cut this joke or she'll tell me that
she prefers something you know it's
story wise to happen and I say to her
I'm not writing the book for you know 40
plus I'm writing it for you know tiny
people and they love this they find it
funny and so I'll always so go back to
either my immediate family or my wider
sort of play you know friends that come
over for playdates and annoy them yeah
was it well let me read you this and you
know it's boring they just walk out of
the room and they're not polite they're
not like you know oh you know they don't
they sugar coat anything no they don't I
love that about them mm-hmm
let's talk about the beach bum okay okay
who is a better kisser okay matt conahey
first scooped us noop just adds a little
sauce he's a cool
just something about being around snoop
you just feel cool though it's Snoop
Dogg you can't you know after I finished
shooting those scenes I put down my
handbag in a slightly more you know just
an edgier way I just feel like Snoop
makes is cooler but Matthew is really
sweet and and he used to call me his
little ginger goat when we were shooting
which used to make me laugh
doctor a actually my name no in a sweet
way it was like but I'm sorry I can't I
can't choose punch you you can't choose
a better kisser okay but but I have to
see them tonight at the premiere when's
it gonna air I mean you have time you
have time they won't see it if I'm gonna
go with my husband yeah that was good on
you that's good that was good on you and
you guys actually just celebrated your
nine-year anniversary yes yes being
married but we've been together for 18
years
holy smokes that's a really long time
yeah I think that deserves a round of
applause yeah I mean amazing and
especially as you guys are both so
successful you know and I think that's
so I know it was recent what did you
guys do to celebrate our anniversary we
actually went to this cute this hotel on
the beach I don't want to say his name
because it's sort of a river hotel and
we rented bikes and we went up and down
and you know we had had some champagne
and it was really fun and yeah and then
we watched a spike Lee movie and that
was it there we go yep one of my
favorite characters from him is Ali G
mm-hmm do you have a favorite character
that he plays are you ever just like
shocked like well I actually really
enjoyed Moran Murad actually from the
new series of who is America yeah I
thought he really was it was really
satirical and I loved how he was sort of
brought out all these kind of alpha men
they would just sort of signing you know
a water board or just revealing I
thought that characters somehow it was
it was a really interesting character so
for the beach bum who would you say was
the biggest beach bum while filming um
probably our director harmony correct
if you just smoked a giant cigar and
wandered around
set he's just such a very creative and
cool guy he kind of he takes he it's
just so unorthodox the way he approaches
filming like we could shoot a scene
somewhere he doesn't believe in
continuity either so you could be sort
of drinking in one scene and then you do
the same scene and you're on a boat and
then he would just intercut them and
it's kind of it's very surreal and I
just think he he was determined to not
have any of the characters evolve will
be dishonest and and as a result I think
it's a kind of an unusual piece of work
because you know you begin an end sort
of the same way but there's there's no
judgment of anyone within the story yeah
so he's I think he's a true he's the
true kind of bohemian at heart harmony
so uh-huh okay so oh that doesn't say
your Instagram first of all your
Instagram is popping I find you to be
hilarious oh thank you I just like I
mean all the girls on Instagram are
always posting like hot girl stuff and
like obese like look how great I am did
it up you post hot girl stuff but you
like tease yourself no I just really
appreciate it he posted a video with
Courtney Cox it was really funny
what's your friendship like with her I
feel like Courtney's the reason we live
in America actually because when we
first came over many years ago she
helped us find somewhere to live and and
then she's just been a huge support
she's just such a kind person and she's
our family here and we feel really
blessed to to have her in our life
you